bigot est Rita écoutez-moi nous ne
voulons tuer aucun d'entre vous mais croyez-moi nous allons
les réveiller un peu tout cela
est à peu près fait nous sommes plus des fantômes de
gens
[Musique]
vous devez garder la foi
ils ne nous écraseront pas
[Musique]
bon vieux néerlandais mon meilleur ami tu sais
comment nous avons rencontré des colporteurs essayant de se
voler en 78 ou à peu près tu
dois t'aimer un feu pour les
bénédictions
bien sûr nous pouvons en avoir cinq et nous pouvons avoir
la connaissance de la baise mais avec cela
vient une certaine connaissance de chaque
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
messieurs le poisson est un
signe de vol cela
fait de nous des frères
parfois des frères font des erreurs vous
ne changerez jamais Je sais que
tous vénèrent la sauvagerie
et tu mourras Savage
ouais
reste à l'écoute reste avec moi tu dois
t'aimer un feu
[Musique]
tu
es grand Rita
[Musique]
tu as de l'argent pour moi garçon vu ton
nom dans notre registre
[Musique]
tu es un homme recherché m.  Morgan peut-être que
lorsque ta mère aura fini de pleurer
ton père, je la garderai en noir en
ton nom,
nous avons des hommes de loi dans trois États différents
après nous avoir chassés de l'Ouest, ils
nous ont chassés à travers les montagnes qui ont besoin d'une
arme supplémentaire, cet endroit n'est pas non  une telle chose
comme civilisé
tu es le seul de ces imbéciles à qui
je fais confiance
où est notre argent
[Musique]